yo bro you know 66% of men start to lose
their hair by age 35 not everyone's like
you cuz you think about it and you're
acting on it dude cuz you don't want to
be that ball bad boy as you get older
yeah I don't want to because my thing is
like they already already have some bald
neighbors by me and I want to kind of do
my own thing you judge them right you
don't be like everybody else judge you
look like a bad guy in a movie all of it
I don't want to always cuz for me it
does not look good
it don't well I don't know dude Bruce
Willis pulls it off dude I took my hair
off on the internet on the UM app and it
is sad well good thing there's hymns
dude good thing there is hams a one-stop
shop for hair loss skin care sexual
wellness for men get your hair right get
your dick right get your skin right they
got it all man prescription solutions
backed by science think about coming
home and have a nice hair a nice suit a
briefcase a job all of that is that
gonna happen who knows bro but what is
gonna happen is hymns are gonna help
your skin your nails your hair I bet
even your beholder look stronger bra
than everybody
lotion that thing up see I goes for you
yeah no more awkward in-person doctor of
it's nothing it's discreet him sends it
straight to your door man straight to
your door order now and you guys can get
started with a hims complete hair kit
for five dollars today right now while
supplies last and you gotta get your
doctor's approval off CC website for
full details and safety info yeah you
want to feel good Manning by taking the
vitamins and taking care of yourself
preventative you're gonna feel good
you're gonna look good I mean even if
you just standing around in the in the
in the market or whatever and trying to
get a trying to sneak and get the hairdo
Bruce Willis bog you better get on hims
go-to for hims calm slash cats that's fo
r hims calm slash cats for hims calm
slash cats see website for full details
in safety info here's an ad from the
king of the sting look man sometimes
your body starts looking crazy dude you
see you know if you want to have a girl
take care of you or something and they
go down there and your butthole smells
like your feet you know dude you know
what I've caught through the other day
of taking a shower I looked in the
mirror it looked like that Clint
Eastwood in a headlock putting my leg
I got great years old my Bush oh you see
you got there long do ya yes Frederick
dong 'less over there dude al-ra'd
Yankovic between my legs broke we're a
Yank if I can start Smashing Pumpkins
wrong person but yeah here's what I'm
saying is take care of your bush a lot
of men's got bush now oh dude look you
want ladies to have it no bush and all
of that or tight little areas or this or
that
take carry on damn crop bro you a little
sharecropper your wiener looks like it's
acidic you know like it's an Orthodox
fella yeah this shows cornrows on your
nuts
you start shaving them bro yeah what are
you getting a finger wave on your nut
bag are you in that Philly fade up
you're buggin taint now you don't want
to do that man
you's manscape yeah tighten up your
Johnson you freakin pervert it ain't
Halloween year-round bruh
okay great line the only way to do it is
man skate manscaped they have the
skin-safe technology so their lawnmower
2.0 finally finally after all these
years a man can take a lawn mower near
is junk without [ __ ] fear God do you
ever and I've been cut my nuts with just
my regular built beard trimmer nice you
snag them nuts who do those things bleed
like freakin oh they'll bleed it's like
a crime scene once I get done oh yeah
the crazy thing is man the lawn mower
will help I used to cut the lawn mower
on go in my room I leave it in the yard
go in my room masturbate so now you can
kind of live the life you always wanted
to live with it with their with their
lawn mower 2.0 it's safe to have around
your junk get 20% off and free shipping
with the code Kay 80s at manscaped
dot-com the holidays is coming get your
man that package hitter yeah ahh to ever
start off free shipping with the coach
Katz at manscape calmness clamps off
with Free Shipping out manscape com use
the code cast get you know that's right
yeah get that junk pumped
Hair Spray good dude really no shit's
dope it's just [ __ ] oh my god bro
you're like my friends had almost let me
die in high school dude I was bleeding
death right from what huh
jumped over a fence and cut my stomach
and arm open on top of it I just got
this hot girls phone number hell yeah
and uh just had a sheer excitement got
her number ran jumped over a chain-link
fence I was like oh I got this ammo
impress her with a trick adrenaline a
drop you your adrenaline was a pump it
oh dude all the journal I've been there
dude I remember my mouth just fell on
the journal and just spitting in the
yard as I ran yeah so I get to the fence
dude I go up steamy snooker style to go
over it cut my stomach and arm open so
then my buddies are like dude ever oh we
were we'd been on mushrooms even gotten
some mushrooms locally how old were you
uh maybe 16 I think okay so next thing
you know I'm bleeding all over my
buddy's like dude you need to suck the
blood out of your arm
I appreciate this stays in your body so
you don't bleed out you know that was
the thought back in the day wouldn't it
your blood style yep and so anyway I
started getting sick and I drank a
decent amount of my own blood well we
went back to my buddy's house I was like
guys I'm feeling real tired I think we
go to sleep you know like yeah man go
get some rest right soon as I turn
around the corner to go sleep I stay
didn't listen because I wasn't really
sure if I should be going to sleep and I
was like her my buddy's really being
supportive and they all are like started
laughing like damn that dudes about to
die bro oh wow like what I'm not very
good friend and foe came right around
the corner I was like what dudes yeah
bad friends bro you don't let me die
dude take me the emergency room you
creak kids yeah that's what it was it
was just kids just kids
yeah he'll die he'll be back next week
all right bring him back dude you gotta
you decide to get so explain the
procedure they take care from the back
yeah and put it in the front yeah people
love the mullet so much I love that long
that European style I think I get a
little bit in the front okay are you
gonna go full long well that's what they
do know they take the back and they put
it in the front so basically I have
mullet in the front
just hasn't grown in yet so it's just
the seeds now they planted and the thing
is you're not losing your hair though
but I don't want to you know what I'm
saying it but something started but if
you want to play from behind your whole
life you can do that Brendon if you want
to get ahead you can do that I see what
you're doing you're in that prevent
defense for how it is you imagine you
bald I'm running the ball bro you're
passing bro I'm probably [ __ ] passing
[Laughter]
oh I saw a couple fall when you show no
I don't know you're what you're really
worried about going bald is their
baldness in your family your mom got
your mom ball
no no mom was not bald dude you think my
mom worked at the VFW dude she's a
bartender there you think ladies in the
60s that parted her hair so hard that it
keeps just party just fell down to the
Sun you ever meet one of those like
there's like a three-inch part in the
middle man that's like nothing black B
when they're going bald but they still
do the cornrows so it starts from back
here
oh yeah it's a small crop oh yeah it's
more sharecropping it's definitely not
you're not running a full crop got a
full set of here on you man you're
worried about it I'll just want to keep
it you know I like having hair in it is
it hurt when they do it well do we
advertise for it all the time on here
you know we're telling people you know
hymns
yeah don't lose your hair why why start
it you know so yeah just take him
instead of doing a procedure well I take
minoxidil that's what I take word but
mmm anyway well looking good today man
ready feel good oh my next hour my next
summer I'm gonna have a nice a lot of
hair like Derek's kind of uh kind of
repurposed hair how you doing with your
hair D loving it yeah I'm getting what
I'm gonna go let it just go you keep it
out to let it go you don't eat you go
bald I mean I will at some point like
how many like that if that's your
attitude then yeah you well you know
your hair here's you tall I mean that's
why it's probably he's doing this you
know but yeah imma [ __ ] let it grow
crazy and just see how crazy and get for
like what the last couple times at this
I can do this you try and look like
Ludacris no and ludecke when Ludacris
came out that was big look that was the
original Luda
when his hair was like
gonna be really crazy mother up the name
Loup de mer that very oh yeah I think I
remember Lewis had the same beat in
every single song forever dude nobody's
heard that nobody's written one beat
more than Ludacris I don't think
Nellie's up there yeah that's true
no he's getting close see I don't know
that Luda this is fast and furious Luda
here oh that's that's that's millionaire
Luda I like to come up Luda you know I'm
saying yeah look good let give me
cheaper cheaper Luda fire bro hit the
picture with the green right there
that's the [ __ ] picture yeah yeah
that's the Luda I will like that's a
Luda Katla you look lovely today cats
looking really much better than Derek
that's a compliment for sure yeah big
grape kool-aid Kat yeah Kat dyed her
hair purple oh really and what do you
use to do it Kat um kool-aid actually
are you serious yeah you bleach your
hair and then you dip it in whatever
color cool look at Derek flare up when
she does now start watering see that I
just saw a mild excitement is that
really what you did no I went to a girl
and she put regular dye in it oh damn I
believe Kat yeah whatever Kat says I
usually believe a lot she's not a liar
huh nobody she wanted to be you'd never
know you'd never know that's what I can
see yeah Kat is very mysterious I think
you know premeditated I feel like I've
no idea what are you premed yes Wow all
Asians are yeah good call sorry Brenna's
don't even know what the joke is right
now do you know it nope I was thinking
about our kool-aid here let's do this
man let's get started boy with that Nick
out I Watchers eman a some fella gave me
this out there beautiful raagh one bro
why are you why are you wearing it my
dad's from Nicaragua is he yeah has a
passport American passport second
citizen was the u.s. god I just don't
believe that really you look like you're
straight why
boy dude do don't pull this Nicaraguan
dude yeah I don't know about oh I'm a
[ __ ] water baby dude that ain't in
land animal somebody [ __ ] on a boat
dude blue fields blue fields Nicaragua
Latinos that Derek here look at you
almost look Mexican yeah you like the
most Mex yeah you look the most white in
here no way well the two camera guys
guys seem very white so [ __ ] Newt
Gingrich dr. Chappelle's way too wide I
can't believe it she fell so everything
with a chew toys got so much anger over
there huggin chewing on a hard piece of
rope over there be careful got our man
sir
I felt like Amy this in Detroit brought
it to me in Milwaukee it's pretty dope
man pretty dope dude yeah I'm polish
Nicaraguan man where are you for when
your pants where were your flubber they
did it after I told them and you paid it
I bet good money to do that Alex man
about five grand I mean it's expensive
yes that's a lot of money it's the most
money I've ever spent on anything
probably in one chump really and just
for your hair yep but do don't want to
have my hair man I want people to be
able to pet me it's not a thing though
huh
if you went bald it you know might lose
your ass how I'm bald
what are you talking about if you and
Chris lose your hair you and Chris
D'Elia yeah the [ __ ] dude if I'm brother
Liz Mair that much I'll do your Chris
and I should do a bald tour that would
be crazy the ball boys where we shave
our head into a tour
that'd be cool people would come just
this yeah up just to get pictures of
your bald head yeah are you crazy
who
worse balled me or him I think probably
me him him for sure is that long face
yeah maybe I'll to get somebody that can
bald him in his sleep
maybe I'll fall asleep at a farm like a
sheep farm or something or lamb doctors
crista do anything to his hair does he
does he do any procedures he crows look
the same as I've seen him eight years
ago Chris wouldn't tell you if he did
Donald think that's why I appreciate you
telling me yeah
Brian tried it just didn't take it
didn't Rogan tried it didn't take yeah
Rogan has the the pulp fiction you know
here's the here's the skull in the back
I think Brian can it I think Brian is a
little scar too you're still usually
isn't scarring though no because what
they'll do is they just take like they
used to take a whole strip and cut the
strip out yeah now they just take like
everyone like every five hairs they take
one out technology so and I love surgery
man everybody knows that so oh did they
give you painkillers what'd they put you
on something dude I remember watching
half of that movie El Camino and then I
woke up kind of midday and you uh I
think it was maybe a general hospital or
something not an actual one but the the
soap opera all right yeah telenovela huh
that's Ari all right all right woody
but yeah cat looks nice today they all
will say that look very pretty today
care and Brennan is upset because I'm
not saying he looks nice look Rose my
host boys Bernie gets jealous when
there's another thought in the room foot
boy for any talking about the hair off
the back your neck dog they did hair in
the from hair in the surgery in the bed
let's get into it
viva la Nicaragua oh let's our little
Russell host boys let's let him get back
a little bit first one oh my god Brendan
looks like the drummer of syndrome of a
Down's forcement finally doing a good
job
probably doing their job yeah Berta
doesn't want to do that
he looks like he has patio furniture
inside of his apartment okay all right
no one's alright it's quicker brother
goes in or out I love this one
Brendan looks like the type of guy to
sit on a popsicle and tell you what
flavor it is they call him the frozen
dessert Whisperer Theo the kind of guy
to smell his finger after giving a wet
willy
Oh from Jack blue Jack fool
Brendan looks like he's coming out with
his own line of Quito corndogs that's a
great idea - yeah yeah a great idea and
bust lamps bus bus lamps we really need
to trademark that dude how do we not get
a bus time you got to be able to bust
enter that fluid or something you know
cuz there's something already in those
yeah the leaf really he dope corn dogs
easy where can you buy a corn dog these
days from you keep touching me bro he
touching me do the wrong way to Wall
Street Derek looks like a turtle who
pawned his shell
[Laughter]
looks like Matt Damon if he was buried
in pet cemetery to do look a little bit
like Matt Damon I do look a little bit
like Pet Sematary that's the part I
thought no bad Damon for sure oh dude go
we'll haunting maybe Jason broke let's
get him missing episode I think I'm good
with Brendon predicting [ __ ]
popsicles
I'm telling corn dog and there's kiddo
core know he's a great idea is solid I
do you got to thank that guy all right
boys
maybe that guy can start making up oh
who are these young oh we got a little
bait club this is hunter and Joey
oh dude hold on I met somebody who do
did we do somebody who had snow in their
beard one time just no King in the
stink-eye you mean cocaine no no regular
snow I outdoor snow from the sky this
guy I met a guy at the show and I think
it was the guy who remember who said his
wife we was smoking weed in the garage
and enough when I met that guy at the
showing on the walk was he cool
yeah he's real cool his wife was there
did she have no ideas no time bro
I don't know like dude go smoke they did
all freaking you know I'll take you from
here yeah you know roll the doobie I'll
take it from here I think I hear your
garage door opening bro I'll give you a
break bro they should have that service
a husband you know a break for the
husband breaker traveling guy that goes
around gives the husband $50 Juggalos
dude
yeah gigolos you ever watch gigolos on
Showtime oh man great TV I watched that
Tito Ortiz that 3430 you were in dude
was cool yeah yeah it was good
man that was fascinating to do you know
any of that story I don't know any a
crazy story right I
can't believe how was this was fighting
more savage in the beginning or it was
way more savage yeah you could do like
kicks down opponents oh you'll see they
like the soccer kicks in the face yeah
they could hit there they didn't show it
on there but there's there's fights
especially those UFC one two three where
they'd like to have them down just be
hit them in the nuts Oh like grab it
there's guys that reach inside and just
grab dick and twist it they can you
tickle too or not you could I don't if
you want to tickle [ __ ] Chuck Liddell
huh knock your teeth out tickle them
[ __ ] hard and fast boy that'll be
heavy my move yeah used to be it used to
be savage back I can't bro watching him
it reminded me of watching a guy it
almost like the way he moves and like
trans like yeah he's like punching and
kicking at the same time it's almost
bizarre to watch yeah so intense I
couldn't even full story though huh oh
it's great you could see how he starts
to get it like those knockouts really
took it to him though oh when he started
getting knocked out yeah that's that's
the game stick around long and if that
happens to everybody like a sad man sad
right
yeah sad was talking about his mom and
his dad right his dad showed up in his
title fight yeah started crying
that's tough yeah dude it's [ __ ] yeah
that 3430 was amazing amazing I didn't
mean to watch it either I just next
thing you know I was watching and it was
good yeah so I'm glad I did man but yeah
I was cool to see you in there who else
was in there Joe Rogan's was in there
and new wells that's it uh none of our
friends
that's it Dana white used to look
healthier huh John thick not like a cool
thick look he's gotten we haven't that
much money is kinda like [ __ ] yeah
gristle he's like Wagyu now but more
more like dry aged before they cut it
yeah okay yeah but anyway sorry to bring
that up it's really interesting man yeah
if you want to learn about the UFC you
don't know about it like me that's
definitely a nice piece of the history
to go and see that yeah it's nuts yeah
it's nuts
how about when Tito started dating jenna
jameson she was like managing him and
[ __ ] yeah it's so bizarre you know how
he taught her to get custody of the kids
he set up cameras in his house because
they were going through like its whole
legal thing and she wanted to take tests
see the kid thing he's like no she's a
drug addict like we're not gonna do this
so they started fighting on social media
so he had cameras all around the house
well
she knew that he could watch her do
stuff because she was like a drug addict
and so she caught all the cameras right
mm-hmm cut all the cords and he had
someone go back in there and it he left
the quartz cut but made it so that they
were set up I thought there are no
cameras and there's like her kids are
playing she's like doing mine to coke so
he got that and just took it to the
quarters like go [ __ ] there you go
yeah that fool Cassie the kiddos you
can't watch you can't cook you could
watch a kid but you're not gonna watch
him well you know you're gonna over
watch you a helicopter parent yeah did
like in a real helicopter though yeah
yeah I did I it's funny cuz I saw him at
the Laugh Factory last year the day
after he fought Liddell he was doing
handing food out at the good dude
at the ultimate great great guys at but
you know they're really really good dude
at the homeless thing oh man laughs I
drink about food yeah um that's crazy
yeah Tito's was great yeah great story
though all right anyway man let's get
into this we're gonna be here we got a
beautiful group of people here today
good to see you today man yeah let's get
some debate club but goes back going
this is hunter and Joey from Texas boys
are so David what's up Brenda chambers
showers shop Brandon Brandon we got a a
dead pug for a debate club
three dead pug would you rather be a
sand pit our abandoned nowadays or would
you rather be a bandit one hundred beers
a hundred years ago we want to know
what's the difference between a hundred
years and going now parent's garage
dad's bike old coroner's office we want
to know
y'all's uh thoughts okay hit me up cat
Drake Drake Derek Derek
Drake Nick these guys man I think I went
to the same school as these guys make
sense uh uh wow what was the question
there commissioner trapped in the garage
would you rather be a copper a
firefighter but they were shit-faced
what no they I thought they said would
you rather be abandoned today or
abandoned a hundred years abandoned
abandoned know as I said a bandit I'd
rather be abandoned 100
years ago because a hundred years ago if
you're abandoned dude it's almost just
like not being abandoned because
everything was you know people didn't
have as much some people didn't have
water but 100 years ago if you had
abandoned your outlaw you're pretty cool
if you're abandoned a hundred years ago
yeah an outlaw we're [ __ ] bandana
start shooting from the hip yeah start
drinking whiskey yeah slap and girls
around that's what they did that's true
I don't use you your abandon yet you're
a pirate you're an outlaw you're like
I'm really like you oh what's up with
this guy your mystery man
now you're abandoned you're like on some
like 1-800 post yeah you're trying
you're a troll on the Internet yeah you
just have an egg for your [ __ ] avatar
and social media are you a bandit these
days now don't you pain to see the Joker
seven times a week a podcaster you're
really sad on a lot if you're a bro it's
just all medicine and [ __ ] dude and
and self-help if you're abandoned in the
old days I think it inspired you were an
original back in the day back of the day
think about people famous people that
were abandoned Peter Pan who else the
kid from home alone okay
have to three times all right hey
awesome terrible pants
can we acknowledge how shitty his
parents were looking for the many times
you [ __ ] we've heard all right what's
going on here dude Kevin by the third
sounds like we've heard a helicopter
parents those are a hang glider parents
not parents doing anything over there oh
dude okay you let me think it's somebody
else that was abandoned um oh uh babe
pig in the city that's a good one let's
have an abandoned off abandoned off
people the people famous really got
abandoned or yeah famous yeah people and
that could be a loose term because basic
oh babe you could go Peter Pan Fievel
goes west was my love and look up his
history Derrick Jesus Christ been
wreck-it Ralph abandoned from a video
game was he really have I kicked them
out oh I had to go to another world hmm
who was Abe from odd world oh all right
I get to go all right I'm just dropping
[ __ ] a ban in fact
yeah oh yeah Justin Timberlake from
NSYNC was he abandoned yep they ditched
him and look at him now no the Hindukush
a degrees so he lives in Cincinnati bro
oh that's abandoned yeah boat off the
island bro
dang dude let me [ __ ] dude you might
yeah you might have won the abandoned
off I got abandoned office off dude do
you think you've any chocolate ale he
got abandoned well his dad abandoned him
but his mom stayed with him that's not
really abandoned I guess whose dad's
just dipped on who's abandoned bro what
makes sense these days is that other
stuff that nailh Delonte West wherever
that guy's name LeBron I thought I was a
tyronn lue step down we're gonna [ __ ]
loosen LeBron fans but actually not as
mean as he lost when he [ __ ] left
Cleveland for the second time for a
[ __ ] bollocks I think that's whatever
him talking about this [ __ ] Chinese
thing super [ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ]
about us Terry that's that was one thing
that's beautiful my China it's like Oh
y'all want to play games get the [ __ ]
get the [ __ ] out we're all said you guys
buy all our cake all your [ __ ] get the
[ __ ] out my B it was like my bad my bad
no no you right man you ride you right
[ __ ] freedom speech yeah take it ball
and get the [ __ ] out of here that's a
China said dude game on bruh and almost
maybe you want to be Chinese it let me -
it's pretty gangster yeah I think they'd
put up with that Kaepernick [ __ ] I
don't know man you get voted off the
island
oh he got abandoned yeah abandoned he
did yeah we're all set we're all set but
they had to pay him though he came back
and got that money not Nikes paying him
yeah that's true somebody's paying him
oh who else got a bantam Anna you win
the abandoned batman bruce wayne piers
gotten more
yeah but he's abandoned because the
Joker killed his parents dude I don't
know man you're making my [ __ ] hair
plugs flare up when you do the grain
bang got abandoned to dee dee
that's my bein broke that's your baby
yeah where are you at oh you think
darkness is your ally you can't do
people from from Lord of the Rings what
we're doing baby
you think darkness is your ally I was
born in the doll [ __ ] lord of the
earrings dude dude they said it would
take a buyout six hundred years to get
out of this here prison oh wow you're go
to read from sha Shan that's all you
ever do is Morgan free and well good
grandfather like that dude how bad was
it for uh for black America that they
had to name their kid Freeman if just to
prove that it was it just make sure it's
very understanding he's a free man yeah
this is a Lord's don't take him from us
they crazy to do that yeah this is uh my
boy Jonathan not yours yeah some black
guys now if you need a black out with a
real white name does he get kind of
stuff gone free man or don't touch him
yeah it's they give him white and hey
yeah that guy's definitely like I need
Mick what are you trying to do here a
black guy named Reba
like oh now this is really something's
not right here man but I got him Philip
looks not bad me Philip Philip that's
such a pill yeah Phil as bad anyways
waves all the time but it's also the
same if you have a white guy name like a
little ceedric or something it's like
Blanc easy there's not a lot of those is
there huh there's some though that they
just need a lot of white guys with black
names you mean don't they call them
Blanc easy it's a black named Erik like
ladarius yeah you don't mean a lot of
white Ladera says there's a couple
though is there do we need that people
said we need to submit some real [ __ ]
guy white guys a black name that's what
we need that's a new thing man you need
it yeah name your uh your kid named one
of your kids that you got getting Tiger
that's almost Tiger and not Tiger yeah
that's true yeah Tiger yeah that's how
good and that he wasn't born tiger yeah
you know yeah we got to get some [ __ ]
we got to get some cooler names dude you
know we do well so these kids uh yeah
being uh I would say be abandon that I
would say be abandoned back in the day
yeah back in the day but for me nothing
is original these days you're when
you're abandon these days you're just a
troll but then you can find other
abandoned kids online you get together
you form a group may be a forum figure
it out
ain't on successful people yup and
that's this past week and it's every
Monday so make sure to check it out man
what do you guys think can under these
guys called you had a couple white guys
in a garage I know it's tempting to look
them up and maybe see what they're about
but I mean I think that's my demographic
white guys in basements make sense I
think about it trying to get at your
feet I love that yeah you could just sit
on the upstairs and just hang your feet
over into the basement moneymakers yeah
talking's really expensive stockings
yeah I love have you ever dated a white
guy cat
one one one and he said something to me
that scarred me racist
he was very well-meaning but he asked me
when we were dating is it true what they
say about Asian lady parts and I didn't
know what he was talking about I was
like what do you mean oh that it's
sideways and I was so confused
because is it supposed to smile at you
when I spread my legs I don't know what
it's very confused but that was a rumor
for a long time I'm David Blaine of your
vagina to do that yeah there was a dream
for a long time and I think was coz
there was some bad artwork that was out
there that led people to believe that
our work
I think somebody had made a painting
that had a region lady on it spread
eagle and I thought oh well that's
different
yeah but also I think it's true I got
like dinosaurs
do they have feathers never know man
watching brendham and that's why you
that's why you broke up with him
no no wasn't the reason why how why was
he what was his first name Nathan Nathan
what hmm
and he also added to his first and last
I saw first day yeah gonna find him
trust me
big possibly people know where he is now
only hurry he like fell off the face of
the earth
what did how old were you when you dated
this white guy pretty young I was like a
middle school that doesn't count
I think the middle school is asking
about your vagina yes yes no idea yes
Rama ties me for like no that's why
interesting I'm trying to yeah me too
[ __ ] Nathan wow dude just a one white
guy never after after that I was just
Asians just Asians only Asians which is
weird cuz Asian guys usually don't hit
on me why I don't know what it is every
now and then it's usually older black
guys wow now it's much more younger
white guys and like Mexican guys my age
and King in the same fans white King in
the same Finn yes that's specifically
white king listening fans yeah in a girl
and her garage garage drinking
dad's [ __ ] beer I'm intrigued by the
older african-american man hitting on
ked that connection what do you see
there Derek can you giving in to us and
it went on there we like damn who
doesn't like them you know huh who
doesn't like I like them man but I but
I'm also you know I get nervous around
everything you know it's time but to see
you guys really out there flexing to see
these older african-american males Lant
you know dropping Damon yeah that's just
interesting you know I don't know these
things I always feel like Asian girls
don't can't see me when I'm around or
something like they don't and not even
like a visual thing that it's like I get
no vibe from them at all I think they
don't get I just am not used to any
Asian vibe I don't have any Asian people
growing up around me so I had no idea
what their vibe was like it's like if
they're into or not if they're into you
if they want to hear from you or to
speak to you or if they what about black
girls black girls yeah more I can I can
relate to more because I'm more
experienced around him have you ever
dated a black guy um nope uh-uh I went
home with one black girl one time and
she had like a dungeon in her house like
a very sexual there was a lot of just
she had a chain mail in the corner you
know from robbing her not Robin Hood but
game of thieves or whatever a chainmail
like the movie saw no a chainmail huh in
her house no she had her [ __ ] like a dog
it was just kind of shared like mirrors
like so that scared you away from yeah
man I was scared I was going through it
makes sense that I was scared she seemed
like a nice girl but that's all I
remember dude yeah do you get mainly
white girls hitting on you or me I get
mainly white girls and then fat black
girls you can keep talking to your boy
ladies oh yeah keep Harlan you like the
fatties they holla confidently and they
say things skinny girls would be like
hey what's up like you're like opened up
the floodgates oh she did who's that
Liz out the [ __ ] uh
[Music]
I got a err on my hair plug man their
sweat no little R that's what you don't
get wet bro look at them tits on that is
good huh but also sometimes black women
make me love some of those want to make
me nervous cuz they would beat us like
in school a lot of times they would
attack you sometimes they get real
aggressive yeah and they're way more
mature than us yes but when I was in
sixth grade they were 23 I felt like
yeah don't shade that black people I
think there's some baby some of that
dick boy and I was like nine years old
no jelly sandwich lady [ __ ] dick
Brennan you wanna haiti's man no shut up
the lizzo also get in shape buddy that's
why I see religion bro you're gonna see
her live you know on the outside you're
like a California guy on the inside
you're a damn ice road trucker boy yeah
bro I'm gonna pay to move
football's never been better you got
basketball popping at the World Series
crack-a-lackin' you got big UFC fights
Friday night Chris Weidman freaking rays
are fighting you can make money bet on
football do it with my bookie bro yep we
had a friend that just won a million
dollars gambling it can happen to
anybody and they got all kind of fight
you can do anything now you can bet on
losers parlays yeah you can bet around
sorry Sanders make a bet on Bernie
sandals health you can bet on a Donald
Trump taking that to Spa you know doing
- you could bet on that the that um a
white guy will play in the WNBA you know
you can bet on a white guy playing the
NBA it's not European you can or you can
bet on a local serial killer do Willie
pull one off this weekend it's anybody's
ball anybody get over/under Monday
through Friday
listen join my bookie right now and if
you join right now
they will double your first deposit
visit my bookie dot AG today
start betting you play you win get paid
get paid you just have to use promo code
ka TS to activate the offer that's promo
code k a TS when you go to my bookie dot
AG - gosh gosh gosh quit cleaning up
around your place do your family doesn't
give a [ __ ] dude get out there and win
that money my bookie
hey G today you play you win you get
paid time to buy fuel more pants look
I'm gonna tell you right now man I know
you struggle reading oh I know reading
for you is a strong bro look I know
we've also been referred to as sentence
buddies because we need each other to
get to the end of them you know second
gang gang bro gang gang rub Matt so
thank God for audible Ottawa's the
world's largest selection of audio books
and audio entertainment including
audible originals I was in a bunch of
books on the plane yeah
yeah what's up now 4th grade teacher
what's up now I know a ton of books
these automotives hit me up about
writing a book and putting one on their
site oh wow
pretty crazy that's pretty cool man time
I need your help dude let's figure out
their you know it's gonna be three
chapters each chapter it's just gonna be
just just draw or do you see coloring
book it's a diorama all the members can
easily exchange any title that you they
don't love at any time every month you
choose one audio book regardless of the
price as well as two audible originals
from a fresh selection you'll stay
motivated to read yeah sign up for free
updates from the New York Times Wall
Street Journal and Washington Post
delivered daily to the app audible
members can easily exchange any title
that you don't love at any time start a
30-day trial and choose one audiobook -
audible originals absolutely free at
that trial visit audible.com slash K 80s
or text K 80s to 5 0 0 - 5 0 0 to get
the 30-day audible trial choose one
audiobook in to audio originals
absolutely free visit audible.com slash
Katie
yes or texts kaes 2 5 0 0 - 5 0 0
someone needs to read you know who they
are get them this as a gift even if they
can't read
you can listen yep Brendan likes to look
at it support the podcast is our buddy
from South Windsor Connecticut what's
going on with you and Brendan yeah Brody
from South Windsor here got a debate
club question for you who did it better
Jeffrey Dahmer or John Wayne Gacy oh
this boy knows the serial killers
apparently well he knows two of the most
popular one but first of all
Casey's his name uh uh Bret I think I
heard he didn't write it down but it
sounded like Bret when he said it okay
thank you for the call brother I
appreciate it I wanna thank you for
taking the time to send us all yeah yeah
murderer John Wayne Gacy was it was it
who's it John Wayne DC or JD yeah well
Jeffrey Dahmer mainly killed gay boys
would have sex with him the Needham
right yeah a little of Filipinos yes and
then John Wayne Gacy was awful he was
the clown that's where all the scary
[ __ ] comes from killed a ton of people I
want to say he did all his killing in
Cleveland is that right or it should
is it Chicago looks like Chicago
Illinois yeah he's from Ellen knowing um
yeah he was [ __ ] scary John Wayne
Gacy went after kids all right yeah he
went after a young teenage boys oh that
was his face both of them did so no
Jeffrey Dahmer went after like gay men
who have sex with Filipinos no only one
Filipino was it just one but a lot of
Filipinos are always young teenage boys
in a lot of ways like they had that very
like you know happy personality very
jovial excited about life they have some
of that same energy Oh Dahmer looks like
a sick man guys look sick yeah he's
Milwaukee's finest there who is
handsomer you think out of these two
guys who I do think you've gone home
with cat let's get out let's get a case
it looks like [ __ ] he's doing his best
he's like 45 minutes I'll tell you what
Ted Bundy mr. steal your girl oh yeah
hello everybody says he was only decent
looking one lot easy but Zac Efron
played him in a movie
I can't get down with the clown thing I
usually would go for the bigger dude
just because I think bigger dudes are
better to cuddle with oh yeah you know
yeah but I can't do with the clown like
you could date a fat guy cat oh yeah
they are the best people to cuddle with
hmm
the best hugs riders on the storm listen
to that way I'll cuddle oh that's me rub
my tip it's a seat in season somebody
yelled out the other day on the
interstate oh and that was in Wisconsin
so when y'all got me it's sucking season
whatever that means somebody said it's
cuffing season we got to cuff somebody
down from winter time you got a lock
them down I heard that over there an
astroid season yeah makes sense you're
doing the summer no wintertime activity
brother dude that's a fall activity you
need that cold breeze oh that's an
October delicacy brother yeah yeah wait
for pumpkin spice lattes and ass with
the other disgusting talking about all
this I would say this out of these two
men what was the question who did it
better who's the better singer Cody both
is both [ __ ] rider Alice I think
that's what they're asking what do you
like more both suck or did they say who
is handsomer who you got I mean in like
a battle off who would pull off five
more murders you think without getting
busted ah John Wayne Gacy yeah hey bunny
was too sloppy with it I'm sorry Jeffrey
Dahmer's too sloppy with it trying to
[ __ ] everybody eat their face and their
dicks and stuff and then freeze it John
Wayne Gacy was that sly [ __ ] clown
hit her yeah j-dub Jehan he was burying
them I know under his home yes so he had
so Dahmer had like the guys running out
on the recipe like apparently one guy
didn't like the [ __ ] curry he made
her something jetted off the door and
they caught him in the neighborhood
thank you
cops returned it was like our bad here
you go and the dude had a [ __ ] hole
in his skull he drilled through his
[ __ ] brain and ran out
butt-naked like dude get back in there
after like what's going on he's I caught
us making a birdhouse out of my friend
yeah that makes sense get back in there
[ __ ] disrespectful of food meanwhile
no sparrows in the apartment ever seen
notice my first clue you show me a bird
now dude or somebody's going to jail
you know Jeffrey Dahmer yeah I better
get back in there man what else we got
I'll take John Casey for 3,000 blaze
yeah I think it was a lot of five more
before yeah more wood he could have
played area I'm Lincoln though if you
look at Dahmer yeah he could easily been
at Abraham Lincoln actor for school you
know it's weird about and I love you
Filipinos man I love all I'm waking up
in the Philippines dude pineapple
[ __ ] blumpkin on my chest a pine
about there by feeling all the rice you
can hand all that sticky rice bro bury
me inside us to get ice marrying some
Pacquiao gloves you following dude burn
me in one big Pacquiao I'll go with my
head poking out the top
dude I'll take out a pack y'all's calves
right now bro them tender oh nice yeah
thank you
[ __ ] calves [ __ ] walk up and down
my tongue dude with a very small pants
on [ __ ] yeah what else you got we got
some relationship advice oh good bleep
advice we can help Christ we discover
hair plugs and Brendan what do you do a
few minutes together blew everybody's
mind eater eating ass spice lattes
before that about the slavery thing
let's keep going Nathan uh uh oarsmen
ores burn from Minnesota Nathan from
Minnesota
so I got some relation interests just
awesome so going into is pretty hard and
all of a sudden she said snapchat
message saying she has something she
don't
so the message until basically was that
she's still living with her ex and so I
creeping on his Facebook and it says
they're still in a relationship this
little handsome devil
god that's tau dude sounds like you got
sidepiece homey a good-looking dude too
man well yeah I think he seemed like a
nice guy I'm not gonna say that the guy
is good-looking Brendan okay here's the
thing though if what's her facebook say
like where is she spent a lot of time
with you cuz
homeboy might if she's that much of a
dying piece he might not just want to
let it go so he's leaving it the
relationship status you know that's true
he might be still caught up you might
still want more he might not ever go on
Facebook anymore either
which could be most people I have no
idea I think my relationship status on
there says I'm like 16 years old so he
hasn't updated it in a while but if
she's sneaking you in and out like it's
only 45 minute type of visits and this
another day yeah
come over you know like only on
commercial breaks and [ __ ] like see what
she has you stored in her phone as yeah
it's Chad from Comcast you might want
ask some questions
[Laughter]
man that's a bummer dude I feel for this
guy but this is also this is what
happens to a lot of women you know and
that's really the sad part is a lot of
this this man could be a lot of women
right now they don't know what's going
on they're talking to some guy you know
he's you know he has girls do it to
don't look at my man this is what
happens all around this is what happened
this is the fallout of all of it brother
he's driving Ronnie as a camper behind
him see they can't protect to his car no
notice that that camper and he's driving
and who knows this guy could be a damn
murderer I'd have to see her to to see
if it the juice is worth the squeeze I'm
saying really I don't need to see your
mansion human no probably as a big heart
and it seems like baby could be a
scumbag though and my boy here that's
true tree him like he's postmates Oh
making sure make sure you come with a
bag you've come to the house you know
yeah and his post mates yeah bring over
some free to bring over something I can
hide the end of the under the bed bring
over some kid some little WOM those Tov
Faye candies that I can wake up in the
middle of night and eat their best thing
was that postman guy always [ __ ]
sticking around all the goddamn time
yeah why is he installing our cable I
think it's interesting brother but yeah
what does he do what do you guys think
Derrick what do you think I mean cool
you're a side piece bro she lives with
him nobody they live together dawg
nobody the movie to break up Vince
Vaughn but here's the thing maybe she
was financially dependent on that dude
they're just broken up she's like trying
to figure [ __ ] out get a job be
independent meets this great handsome
dude no yeah that's beautiful I found
like the nicest thing probably not she
getting double dick well now who knows
if they're having sex he didn't mention
sex bring up my eyes I guarantee you a
[ __ ] yeah come on you old for this they
could just be dating Brandon come on
what do you think Kat mmm he seems like
such a nice guy but yeah he sighed dick
where's he where's he come from he
from Boise Minnesota Oh nice people to
sidekick he just got heard that time
yeah he's that Papa he's that Peyton
Manning Papa John's dead she's that hot
girl Caesars oh man look I say look but
do you think he's really into the girl
cat or do you think he's just wondering
if he's a sidepiece or what's going on
do you think he's really into her I
think so
I mean he's into her enough to make a
video and send it in and wait for a
response
yeah she's obviously not a listener or
watcher this show well she will be soon
dude yeah she's gonna get to her I hope
she sends a video like alright I got one
for you guys so I'm kind of seeing this
guy inside my boyfriend but he's really
nice and we do share one thing Tom when
we love King in the stained glass
gangbang has a drive-thru
I keep pretending he's a post mate and
installs our cable and then dicks me
down and good luck man yeah what woody
what did he want to know from us oh just
I feel like we helped them I think yeah
I think sometimes you just need some
support on what your kind of question it
seemed like you just questioning it man
so I think just play it by ear just
don't get too caught up until you know
it's for real because she's still living
with this man
you don't wanna get shot by this man
that's true people be sure he's doing
all he can he has a girl living with him
he has on his Facebook during a
relationship if you got a court you saw
those things yeah you know what you're
signing up for it bro you sign this
lease and you get shot bruh no you know
people are gonna take your side very
easily yeah be we'll be shooting these
days and if she's bad enough if she's a
baddie getting double dick like this
she's a valley homeboys gonna you know
try to keep yeah bang bang dude
buzz buzz yeah good luck dude all right
here's a little flunk my boys my nuts
[ __ ] sorry sorry what that in
the corridor
I'm just a little bit high-strung today
because I'm on some pain medication from
this head surgery this is hot Lucy
catarrhal Oh Lucy fur is a beautiful
beautiful jig like a beautiful reptile
she is a bad around her neck she's a bad
that's the least of her [ __ ] words
about look at her [ __ ] teeth bro
I think she looks nice and I like where
your head that I like I like I like this
positive feel right now she clearly
stapled her eyebrows that's cool that's
cool better that's brave did imagine
going to bed at night instead of just
closing your eyes stapling them shut
that's like I'm getting sleep no matter
what anybody else wants yeah imagine
feeling your way to the kitchen in the
morning to make a [ __ ] a - gorilla
egg or to eat flies imagine you can't
find your staple remover and you have to
[ __ ] drive to work with your eyes
staple I think that's what she wants bro
yeah imagine waking up thinking her
[ __ ] a lizard dude Oh imagine laying
on the road after rains in the Sun and
enjoying it Oh imagine laying on the
rocks like an iguana ha beautiful ah
dude
now we're talking about it belly up baby
get them raise you to God that's
somebody's aunt huh yep she graduated
from University of Wisconsin I don't
believe that and she did this herself
the horns are all clay this is all clay
oh she's a makeup person I think yes she
did this the tats are real though that's
a real is the she for real - I think
maybe I don't have an idea artist she
was gonna have to do this stuff is there
any other facts on so she went to unity
with Scott Wisconsin Badgers baby ain't
no right now don't jump on the train
dude well yeah they get the [ __ ]
running back there Badgers bro I know
that's not your team's LSU bro I know
but just on the badger trip imagine
being a badger and doing something
they're always good dude no he's pretty
solid they're deep water fed white boys
great running back that's what they do
that's
but this year they've taken it to
another level and scored a few more
points than usual
and I'll see what's up pac-12 sucks
monkey nut so okay what do they want to
know about this lady that was a flaw
they just want to do this one let's
Florence somebody she's only cool in
October you feel me like this isn't
she's not coming to the holiday parties
besides Halloween right that's a thing
definitely she doesn't seem like that
Christmas Eve kind of bad girl like if I
if I she seems nice but if I saw her
under the mistletoe dude I would shoot
that thing missile so go bro that's what
I would do like quadri is Mayo broad
[ __ ] be out that [ __ ] I'd be like
his brother rock and shoot this [ __ ]
right the tail but those sharp teeth
dude imagine you can't find out you got
to open envelope some mail or something
you can't find something your lady's
right there to help you
I'm pretty pretty handy you know imagine
you want to get in what can I so of
Abita of a pure beanie weenie dude don't
even tuna man this is dangerous he has a
lead poisoning - my buddy
mercury do my buddy Billy rich ate some
led braids like 19 cans of tuna in a row
dude and once you were Mercury's going
dude you it's like you're on a shift
like on a scary ship all the time
started rocking back and forth bro for a
while and he's better now shot out BR
bro there might be some mental health
racial line gang brothers do could walk
across a park damn by himself dude
pretty cool
you like this ant though good luck what
are you talking about good luck dude I
mean just in life dude if you really
wanna pretend uris tatted up lizard give
me a tough road for you oh she looked
honestly she's beautiful for one
beautiful song that dude you keep saying
that yeah because I mean it but she also
looks like an aquarium [ __ ] a bowl of
Fruity Pebbles so I think there's kind
of a mixed bag going on here
what I can't what the part that gets me
is the bat around her neck the bat
that's the least of my [ __ ] really no
I'm more worried she's gonna see this
show and put a [ __ ] voodoo spell on
us dude
she hasn't better rounded neck
Oh what sorry is that a bad around of
your neck are you just happy to say on
darkest magic bro this is like you uh
you're playing Dungeons & Dragons and
you rolled a seven thousand but outside
of that she seems look she's a big smile
Hardy you know looks healthy
looks like she's healthy kind of neck
full lips full lips has fake horns they
look except she doesn't get a lot of
sleep very similar to lizard they don't
sleep a ton yeah she has bags on bags
around her eyes
lizard bags dude that's actual luggage
bro talk about luggage baby somebody can
make a beautiful pair of boots out of
this lady or a purse oh man we're going
to hell dude you know it's crazy you
know she's already there that's her
trick she shows up people say mean
things they go to hell BAM she's right
there and get some get by get to me bite
some but ya seem like a great aunt yeah
yeah next we got Kristen and not Krystal
full chocolate body on the left that's
frowned upon in Hollywood but Bob Dylan
gets away with it
look at this Cadbury legs bro that is a
chocolate body right check out the ink
on that sculpture not mad at at all she
is side to [ __ ] uh now cap what do you
guys see when you guys see a kind of an
orange chicken [ __ ] like this what do
you guys think you see this bronze [ __ ]
what do you think man sorry I'm on these
pills my hair you know yeah I'm also on
pills that's why I say all these
outrageous things I uh I'm on whatever
deals oh man it's I think it's just
Halloween it's just the seasons Howie we
don't you know she has the face of mr.
freeze
[Laughter]
oh good you guys are going to hell Oh am
I going to hell my medication man dang
and that's a compliment dude but she'll
never get scoliosis for sure that is the
whole world just woman I've ever seen in
my life
she'll never get scurvy dude that's for
damn sure
huh okay beautiful though huh how the
great the one on the right the blonde is
aunt Kristen she was married a former
Harlem Globetrotter Roy's a zoo bird ooh
somebody begin that [ __ ] dude dude in
Harlem Globetrotters you don't shoot all
those crazy shots and I have a nine-foot
[ __ ] panther tails bro you could jump
off a six-story building and land in
that lady's forcing meanwhile homeboys
balls deep in her [ __ ] yeah my god
you know blacks here I'm here to grow
crystals on the the bodybuilder and
she's married to a cop and they're both
King listing things wish I would have
known that before I called him mr.
freeze oh I think crystal looks
beautiful too I think Kristen looks like
a I think she looks healthy I think she
looks stronger than Theo I think she has
bigger arms than me well here's the
thing also you don't know the way that
these performers in these bodybuilding
competitions look and the way they are
on game competition weekend different
people totally different things
hold on eat up say that right now she's
body up but she has a dumper out the
back oh dude that truck oh but she
doesn't eaten anything in a month though
there's only zero carbs oh dude yeah
white teeth I'm jealous of them I'm
confused the girl on the right is there
for what reason
sister support I thought my older
sisters your sisters Brennan yes well
ones black ones white well I'm gonna ask
you she she spray tan black spray tan
full chocolate body so she looks like
this sister she looks like her normally
yeah though i girl yeah
if you that's the thing when these late
that this is like before and after
really yes correct
correct she's eating tilapia for the
past six years to look like this
yeah oh dude she's definitely uh yeah
should the dedication the discipline to
get in that [ __ ] shapes insane yeah I
can't even imagine dude especially when
your vagina starts getting all [ __ ]
hard oh well they turn mm-hm
be cool cool I'm trying to be core your
baby ice come out in sneakers bro that's
how hard your [ __ ] is so jacked the baby
comes out with a helmet on it also comes
out your dick hole because that's what
happens
cuz they take so many steroids just
trying to be cool there's a cop Brendon
oh you know cops will shoot anyone
that's true what city are they so I know
to cancel that tour date I think I'll
say this I love cops and I think half
the people that get shot deserve to be
shot at least half 75% well here's the
thing you walk up to anyone right now
and punch them in the face and say you
know what that's for every everyone's
gonna be like even if they don't know
what it's for we've all done something
they're gonna go back years and make
that make sense yeah I did it so I'm not
singing everybody deserves to get shot
but I'm not surprised if I drove around
all night drinking coffee and stuff I'd
shoot somebody yeah if it's probably on
that pay come on dude
yeah I think cops could probably get
paid two hundred thousand dollars a year
at least tough gig you know harder to be
a cop everybody hates you yep so I think
it's nice that this guys out there
support and keeping us safe and his
wife's able to lift gym and lift and and
do do nice meals and meal cutting and
everything I also think it's cool that
body bones the last safe place we need a
full chocolate body yeah and not take
heat for it that's true and I say go
darker next time oh yeah she's too wide
for me too
- body's gonna go darker you want to win
or not did she win 51 she's got that ice
on her unless you want yeah I say go
darker go dark dark you know what I'm
saying
listen you wanna be the best you got to
go darker you got to get more dekha
that's what I'm saying lit be changing
him to lift Trisha you know and lift it
all there's not Frieza if you have me
but yeah a beautiful couple and he
seemed these girls seemed like they love
each other and I'm glad and we love you
guys Rousey just joking shot me that
guy's wife is a cop I don't know man oh
yeah well no duper on drugs
remember mr. white first this is Jack
from Washington State this is Jack
what's up deal what's up Brendan this is
Jack from Washington State beautiful
state gang buzz buzz I got a king and
hosting it for you eating sunflower
seeds and spitting them on the ground
[ __ ] yeah
in the city hell yeah Cantor sting it
[ __ ] mangoes good brothers gus-gus bro
okay oh you spit on your phone dude at
the uneffective brothers all the guys in
these snow with no shirt on you gotta
respect that is that snow snow varmints
the real bear grylls right there dude
god damn dude horses in the bag daddy
[ __ ] snow in the front
um Sunfire seats got a [ __ ] yeah nothing
more American than sunflower see just I
spit those things wherever dude I like
to load my cheek up like a chick monk
and just fire those puppies out the
window you feel me even those [ __ ]
Dodgers cap on and just [ __ ] put on
some ac/dc nothing more American than
that we smoked we used to spit him and
hey we'd catch them in our mouth he'd
spit the things out he'd spit him in the
air high enough we could catch him
that's not sad at all do you like
pumpkin seeds it's American yeah I like
them them boys are those thick hitters
Oh pumpkin those things
[ __ ] yeah deep throat you put more
than three in your mouth oh yeah dude I
put three in my mouth bro me you know
I'll meet anybody anywhere those thing
to make you real fired up yeah you ever
had sunflower seeds doesn't seem like
your vibe really you mean cat definitely
seems like you said different types of
seeds and different types of you know
unique rare meats cat really I don't see
you buying like a pack of barbecue you
ever had their barbecue a ranch it's no
I go to I mean I don't see you eating
sunflower seeds every day oh you don't
every day no I see Brendan Brendan looks
like definitely every assistant coach on
every children sporting by far dude -
whistles even though after the first
time that the real coach is like you
look like [ __ ] what are you talking
about worse DJ for deaf people can't
hear me that's gonna hear procedure
you're dressed like a loud mind
Andy day keeps going grabbing guys dicks
in the middle of the street we grab my
dick twice in shreveport two different
times so dude he texts me to suck my
because I didn't save his name is just
said and big a wild night the other
night meet some hot chick soon you pitch
him like this bruh that's bananas dude
yeah you look like a [ __ ] loud mom at
a bakery dude you're just like oh I'm
gonna put these lizards in my la
[Laughter]
yeah what else we got D up next we got
love you man
good to be here with you we got matheus
look at this guy stealing black people's
names first of all he's from Belgium
banana right but he is pavlov Mattias
sounds like a quarterback for LSU is
that a ponytail at the back is it the
Hani bad year that you what's up Brandon
I'm Matthias you can call me Manny I'm
from Belgium that I'm coming to you from
well that rescue center in Ecuador the
animals here are brought in by the
police confiscated by out of the black
market most of them were that's
illegally owned however I know they knew
us depending on the state where you are
it's legal to own exotic pets and I
wanted to know you that's about it so oh
damn
example beds are stinging that it's on
highway 9 so keep it up muchas gracias
amigo dude King exotic animals you're
miserable though dude white people take
it too far like that guy in New York who
had a tiger and a crocodile in this
[ __ ] apartment they start fighting it
to rush out the goddamn building you
ever seen that dude
I like the six
[ __ ] so bad idea you just fell asleep
viju mangia oh you're right you're right
that's coming hard
you're like dude when you're right
you're right [ __ ] dude when you're right
you're right dude hi I mixed the realm
yeah bro also hang out with dudes lace
in your afternoon fortunately watch
Jumanji this is beautiful I don't even
Emer you're some big old eyes nothing
looks like yous twisting his nipples -
wow that thing I'll climb - you touch
you man think beautiful that's not sugar
you know what do you want to marry this
bum well just problem the monkey has a
side piece I don't know if they're in a
relationship yeah what is maja says in a
relationship on Facebook
the monkey won't stop cheating on him
well here's the thing I think Mathias
for uhm in America I think a lot of
people have started to get a lot of
people get animals and they I think they
they just don't take they they're not
prepared to take care of them that's
well no cuz you by a crocodile when
they're young like oh this is cool
saltwater crocodile even my bathtub six
months go by the things I'll [ __ ]
crocodile can't take a [ __ ] anymore
think it through
also exotic animals this day and age
yeah you know in America we're always
trying to one-up each other we're trying
to flash it that used to be Rams used to
be dope cars dope houses now next thing
you know they got a guy in Cleveland
with three girls locked in his basement
for a decade he's like oh come over and
see these crazy lizards are humans
brother just painted scales on one of
them so that's my file deed
but scales up that's I think within
America we've gone past the point of
like what's the like real purpose of it
and more to the point of like how can we
make it in like you know what I'm saying
I'm doing it for the gram these yeah
this is trying to get likes like some
dude by the high you know the other day
and walked it down the street that ain't
safe bro yeah that ain't safe yeah you
can't be heaven you can't be doing hyena
hahaha dude you know there's nobody
nobody your neighborhood has a hey NAT
hanging a defense kit you know yeah but
also don't bring your hanging a dog
parking like just a Bullmastiff i've
ever seen one bro yeah why is it
laughing over there by the fence
yeah just gives your favorite movies
black panther doesn't you have to buy
one on the black market man things are
dangerous
yeah dude why are they watching The Lion
King and drawing a [ __ ] evil plan if
it's a bold master but look man I think
I think Americans were becoming an
endangered species in some way do we
need to be rescued brah
so I think we could use probably you
know I'd be in a Y being a woman shirt I
wouldn't hide in a man's shirt like that
the animal but I think it's beautiful
what you guys are doing over there yeah
I want mine like an armadillo but yeah
people are getting tigers people are
getting elephants people are getting
people you know it's getting spooky man
sex trafficking is big over here they
say it's big did they say it's
bumper-to-bumper I haven't seen one
person next abuts bro you know nuts too
but all the women that I meet just want
to be hookers I agree it's like that's
the job you don't but every now and then
I guess there's one that's you know
caught up in a dope game and they're
being abused but just don't [ __ ] any of
these animals bro yeah I'm just saying I
want armadillo so we could get like a
mascot for the studio what could it be
what about a bat just [ __ ] flies on
[ __ ] everywhere we're just like goddamn
them can't sting it alright dude I'm
just [ __ ] everywhere yeah guano
guano
I think every night what is that guano
he's been sure - oh yeah yeah man I
think um and what does this guy want to
do he wants to bring this into the
country you know I just wanted the king
of
do you guys like it remember when Bieber
got stopped in like Goss trailer some
[ __ ] he had that pet monkey romera that
yeah he's a pet monkey Timon Jack that
thing dude how could you not have a fat
monkey in Australia there's so many
animals there you everything is so dude
I should grab a call off the street come
on our dragons dude they got everything
over there yeah we could use a mascot in
here though
maybe an ant farm see monkeys I suggest
a bat yeah just rats and bees or maybe
an Isis somebody's been in Isis and we
could freaking slap them time feed them
dirty Fritos yeah have another boy have
another beat up a son but yeah man thank
you for sending in thank you for
watching this in another country bro
yeah man Philly's um feliza
not not it's not Christmas yet we're
literally el Dia de los Muertos bien
bien
we have a good Halloween wait oh wait oh
what else we got that's it boy that's it
Vic today yeah how's a fast one iguana
boy no bueno brother wanna Gras no
buzz-buzz oh man I feel like we went
through a lot during this one did you
know I felt but did feel wrong I don't
know man how long do we go three hours
three hours that's cool three hours I've
got to go to a funeral I know a dude
sorry brother sorry about your friend
man it's alright I appreciate it
yeah Sarah I was in a bad mood today man
I do here's me too I feel like I was in
a bad mood did you I did did you maybe I
was being mean I don't know yeah maybe
you were being mean to me I don't know I
didn't feel great bill
you didn't yeah you seem like yeah but
seem like there's a little bit maybe I
was a little bit mean I'm sorry if I was
that's alright your friend died you have
here that you're trying to fix yeah so I
don't know dude um this comes out this
is next week so you get any day through
this week tonight yeah you know what
yeah yeah it does
oh well [ __ ] I'm in Philly Thursday
Friday Saturday Philly helium Derek's
busting nuts out there Hasan's me shoot
this [ __ ] ak-47 me climbing out of a
frickin
out of a Peruvian guys shirt sounds a
[ __ ] illegal [ __ ] animal and I
bring him all over the state we had
stopped every but I also in another
sense I'd love to see people making
their own Zoo small zoos you know I like
you know I like small zoos and I like
petting zoo cemeteries at your own you
know when I was growing up they had you
know your neighborhood have a couple of
dead people you know little family
cemetery in the yard yeah why not what I
have to bury my loved ones where
everybody else is buried yeah yeah why I
got to drop to the city limits to see
your shitty animals when my neighbors
got [ __ ] nine straight a treeless
living in the back
you know yeah dude I just went up
petting zoo and my son grabbed the show
this sheep this thing was dope there's
no better place to show a child a bunch
of animals dicks up closer than a
petting zoo dude it's one way to look at
it man you know I don't pet lopat hi
it's what I tell the kids yeah things
gonna spit at you things better things
with chewing gum that's what I tell them
all right
just spit out some sunflower seed you
keep going and then November it's a
Dallas Salt Lake City Utah get your
tickets
I feel [ __ ] over to thee December 10th
I'm gonna be at The Wiltern in Los
Angeles so you can get tickets to that
oh and um we got I'm gonna be at Oxon
Hill Maryland looks like it's gonna be
January 17th or the 25th I'll let you
guys know this week and then and that's
it and I might shoot a special coming up
in Chicago so uh when you shooting that
I don't know we kind of lock the dates
down right now prowl do you men see me
go thanks bro but yeah Gang Gang buzz
buzz buzz lightyear
[Music]
the king
[Music]